how are you still on YouTube like you
know my thread I'm telling you man we
argue with each other like if I say
anything about kovid for the most part
Tim will be like no no no and then we'll
let go at it and we never make
definitive claims very very rarely make
definitive claims about things we don't
have proof it's it's basically just like
look we're reading Politico here you
know what I mean hey man if YouTube's
got a problem with Politico the BBC CNN
all reporting this well then we're all
asked well I mean marjor Taylor green
got got zapped off of social media for
saying that if you were really
overweight that was probably a bad idea
vis-a-vis covid and exercise would be
helpful and then you you know lo and
behold you later see CNN and the CDC
crash up those positions